This is now becoming a pattern.
Donald Trump very clearly does not want to
take questions from reporters right now because
the questions would overwhelmingly be about
his tax returns, about his paying no income
taxes for 10 of the last 15 years, about his
paying 750 dollars in federal income taxes
in the year he was elected.
And in his first year as president, his exaggerations
of the profitability of his businesses.
And since Donald Trump doesn't want to take
the questions, he's just bailing out without
taking questions.
At public appearances yesterday, Trump did
a total propaganda event at the White House
Rose Garden to talk about again how great
Corona Virus testing is going watching the
event.
It seemed like it was April all over again.
Trump talking about developing rapid tests.
He had the same people, including his admiral,
talk about how the rapid tests work.
Mike Pence spoke and spoke and thanked Trump
for his great leadership on Corona virus.
It was like going back in time, six months,
as if the last six months never even happened.
But it was all a carefully crafted and planned
ruse to create the appearance that Donald
Trump isn't hiding.
But getting him off stage immediately without
answering any questions, because, of course,
the questions would all be about the insane
bombshell tax return revelations that Donald
Trump has worked for years to keep secret.
Here is Donald Trump wrapping up the event
without taking a single question.
And very importantly, vaccines are coming.
But we're rounding the corner regardless.
But vaccines are coming and they're coming
fast.
We have four great companies already, and
it's going to be added to very rapidly.
They're in final stages of testing.
And from what we're hearing, the results are
going to be very extraordinary.
So thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
And thank you very much.
Great job by Abbott right from the beginning.
Great job by Abbott.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Bye-Bye.
Everybody just going to walk back into the
White House without answering any of the dozens
and dozens of pressing questions about the
insane allegations about me.
And like any good Trump event, Trump struggled
to speak, not recognizing the word hospice
on a script and calling it hospice.
This is odd, 10 million for home health and
hospice care, hospice care agencies.
He just cannot get through one of these without
making a fool out of himself.
Here he is having a big sort of dog and pony
show, having a corona virus, tests done by
the admiral for the cameras to come up and
demonstrate how these tests are performed.
You'll do this very nicely, I think.
Good luck.
Hope you don't test positive.
Funny guy, right?
It says if it's April all over again and we
don't know how to test for Corona virus, but
we're figuring it out.
And it's news that we have tests.
Now, you'll remember the day before yesterday
at Trump's press briefing when people when
reporters tried to ask Donald Trump about
the tax stuff, he did anything he could not
to answer.
Here he just scolded a reporter for asking
about his taxes when he had called on somebody
else for being a rude person.
You've taken Federal's.
I didn't call you.
I'm talking to him.
You should be more respectful of this gentleman.
They're very rude to him.
But I will tell you that I look forward to
releasing that.
I look forward to releasing many things.
I'm going to release many things.
And people will be really shocked.
Trump will release lots of things and people
will be shocked.
Well, I'm convinced.
I'm not worried anymore.
Trump also called the New York Times story
about his taxes fake news and is still claiming
that he just can't release anything because
he's under audit.
We are not releasing.
They are not publishing the tax returns.
They're not showing that out there.
They're saying to protect their sources in
your tax returns.
Does that sound right to you?
Your pay a couple hundred dollars here.
Circles.
It's totally fake news media.
So we went through the same stories.
You can ask me the same questions.
Four years ago, I had a litigator's and talk
about it.
Total fake news.
No, actually, I paid tax.
And you'll see that as soon as my tax returns.
It's underwrote it.
They've been under water for a long time.
The IRS does not treat me well.
They treat me like the Tea Party, like they
treated the Tea Party.
And they don't treat me well.
They treat me very badly.
It's all totally fake, fake, fake news.
Eventually, Trump is going to have to talk
about this, right?
I mean, can Trump I mean, maybe he can you
tell me, can Trump really avoid questions
about this through to the election on November
3rd?
Will Chris Wallace tonight in the first debate
as the moderator, will Chris Wallace bring
up the tax situation?
If so, I mean, you have to assume Trump is
going to be prepared with something in case
taxes come up, whether people will buy it.
I don't know.
Donald Trump's former personal lawyer, Michael
Cohen, is insisting that the tax stuff is
just the beginning of this type of thing for
Donald Trump.
And note that when Michael Cohen testified
months ago was exactly right.
Michael Cohen testified months ago or was
it a year ago?
I don't even remember when it was at this
point.
Time has flown by.
But Michael Cohen testified Trump will artificially
either inflate or deflate the value of his
assets, depending on what he's trying to achieve.
And it turns out that he was right.
Here's Michael Cohen reminding us of that.
So, Joy, let me start with what I know and
to which I testified before the House Oversight
Committee in February of twenty nineteen.
What I stayed was that Trump fraudulently
inflated the value of his properties in order
to receive favorable terms from lenders, only
then to underreport their value for tax purposes.
Basically, what they did is they called him
a liar in chief.
That everything he says is a conflation of
the truth and finalized by saying that the
valuation of Donald Trump's assets is so disproportionate
to their real worth that we have no idea the
true valuation of anything that he owns.
I mean, it's gaslighting to the extreme.
Trump has lied for so long about literally
every facet of his life that the real truth
is, according to The New York Times, it's
it's shocking.
I started getting emails from people saying
Trump is going to pull out of tonight's debate
last minute because it's just too risky given
all of this tax stuff.
I still believe that the debate will happen.
I hope that you'll be there with me if it
does.
I will be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook
starting at eight thirty PM Eastern Time,
five thirty p.m. Pacific.
Don't miss it.
We want it to be.
Maybe it'll be the most successful stream
we've ever done, but we will all be together
for it and we will see if this topic of taxes
comes up.
I hope that
it will.
We
will see.